at this point I was able to look past
where I've seen but what I found that
gave me a deep pit in my stomach hello
and welcome to all Danes a creepypasta
or stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce
my name is cz and I will be your server
this episode today's special is from the
little demons in our lives
plucked fresh from the cabbage patch and
cooked for you we hope you enjoyed these
selections from our kids menu number one
I found some disturbing pictures in my
child's backpack my wife and I first
decided to send our daughter Ella to
preschool when my wife went back to
school to get her nursing degree Ella
was about four years old at the time and
we were primarily concerned that she
would have a hard time fitting in since
all the other kids in the class had been
together for a couple of years already
at that point the first couple of weeks
went off without a hitch
or at least we didn't notice any issues
until one afternoon in September when
Ella wasn't feeling well and went to bed
right after we picked her up from school
she had her backpack dumped right next
to the door and my wife commented on the
fact that it was surprisingly heavy
considering how small of a bag it was we
were curious about what exactly they had
given her that would make the backpack
so heavy so we decided to pop it open
and take a look all that we had given
her when she started preschool over the
basic pencils markers ran a pad of paper
extra clothes perhaps a couple other
things that I'm forgetting right now but
the point is we were very surprised to
see what we found in the backpack it was
filled to the brim with loose papers it
was a complete mess almost as if she had
just stuffed the backpack full of papers
one sheet at a time there must have been
hundreds of sheets in there if not more
the strangest thing is Ella had never
really been a very messy child she keeps
her room clean for the most part and
she's the kind of girl who never really
likes to get her hands neck
naturally my wife and I emptied out the
backpack and tried to sort through the
mess what we found were mostly drawings
the typical stuff you would expect from
a young girl with the grass at the
bottom and the Sun in the top corner of
the page
most of the drawings had three
characters who I can only assume are
supposed to be Ella my wife and I most
were repeats or some variation of this
basic formula the three of us standing
in front of a house the three of us
standing flowers at the beach etc etc
not all the pages were drawing some of
them just contains black trans girls all
over the place it was almost as if she
was trying to color the page black I
remember doing that when I bored in
school as a kid as well so I wasn't too
concerned until I saw that there were
more of them subsequent pages contains
less black scribbles and more white
states and all of the line scheme would
be completely random from what I can
tell we said something about getting her
a bigger folder and continued to sift
through our daughter's drawings for a
while until my wife got a call and I got
hungry and want to go grab some from the
fridge after that the issue never really
came up again to the next month or so we
got busy with life and well if you have
kids you know how parenting can be
anyways one afternoon in October I was
in Ella's room getting her ready for bed
when she had to use the restroom so I
continued to sit in there and wait for
her when I noticed another messy stack
of papers we have a little table set up
in her room that she can use for her
arts and crafts and once again there was
a huge surplus of drawings pouring out
of her backpack I was starting to wonder
if they do anything else at this
preschool of hers besides is free time
to color when I noticed something
strange there was a new character added
to the family portrait and he looked
disturbing to say the least
who is a tall slim bald man wearing long
white robes this figure was completely
devoid of any color except the eyes and
mouth which were scribbled in a dark red
it looked like she had jammed the crown
into the page as hard as she could to
produce the eyes and mouth resulting in
a much more intense pigment in those
areas other than that this character and
the areas surrounding his outline were
the only parts of the page that were
completely colorless what was even more
disturbing was the fact that this
character and my wife were frowning
while Ella and I both had huge smiles on
our faces it just didn't sit well with
me I continued to look through her
drawings and found that this fourth
person was in every drawing as I flipped
through them I noticed this guy came to
be staring at my wife and some of the
drawings he seemed to be standing behind
her I was legitimately creeped out by
this but told myself that it must be an
imaginary friend or something I
continued to flip through the pages and
ended up coming across more of those
black scribbles but these ones were what
I can really only describe as more
violent more intense it was the same
thing where it looked like she had
matched the crowning to the page at this
point I was able to look past what I had
seen but what I saw next gave me a deep
pit in my stomach she had drawn pictures
of my wife laying at the bottom of the
ocean where I dribbled out in black
friend and she was wearing a huge frown
to my own dismay this wasn't the only
drawing like this she had drawn the same
picture over and over and over my jaw
hung a gate as I tried to comprehend
what I was looking at when I realized
that my wife in the bath right now Ella
had probably gone into that same
bathroom
before I could react I heard a cold
voice from behind ready you Goering I
turned to see Ella standing at the door
I tried asking her about the pictures
but she just refused to talk about it
and climbed into bed this wasn't just a
case of kids will be kids
she had a most serious tone about her
thankfully my wife didn't mention that
anything could happened while they were
in the bathroom but we were unable to
get Ella to respond to any of our
questions about the pictures
now we're considering seeking
professional help
number two
play with me are you awake why are you
hiding I don't mean you any harm I know
it's great but I want to play you
haven't taken it for nearly a month I
want to have tea with you again
I promise not to spill I didn't know it
was hot
sorry it ruined your favorite shirt I'm
happy to have can hit biscuits with you
today your eyes are beautiful with that
tress I wish I had such mouthing I don't
turn away from me why are you ignoring
me
is it because you don't love me like
your other dolls no don't put me away I
didn't mean anything by it please love
me I'm not as pretty as your other doll
but I want a section too
don't leave me tonight cries and
scratches in the night where are you she
took me out one more time please enjoy
your game it'll be easy I promise
please don't fret you only want to play
with you we can be best friends forever
I'll never leave you I thought you were
lonely isn't that why you have so many
dolls you hugged me and lost me now why
do you hate me we have lots of fun
together is my hair - knotted or my
dress - dirty I know it's late but will
you play with me one last
I hate seeing you cry we can play hide
and seek you hide and I'll see if you
win you can do whatever you want with me
and I promise to behave if I win and you
have to play with me when I want to play
I'm glad you're letting me out to play
this time I promise not to disappoint
don't worry I won't peek not one sip be
quick though they are not I'm coming for
you there are you are you in the closet
I thought I heard a door close
no okay perhaps you went downstairs I
can't wait to find you if you go all the
way to the basement careful you know
you're not supposed to play down here oh
you chose this doll the one that was
made for us to play in together happy
that you saw
now we can be together forever
don't worry no one will find us here I
make sure that the store is rough and
mountainous what's up you're hungry you
saw another key party
what you mean no I don't know how long
it's been
like up I want you roll it up time to
play why are you so cold you need a
blanket I can finally answer me why are
you ignoring me again in a long time
thinking I know why did you have to die
dark and cold but I won't believe you
number three Jason Jason this is a story
that took place six months ago when my
first son Elliot had just turned five
years old
Jason was first introduced into our
lives when we decided to hold off
sending Elliot to kindergarten since his
birthday was so close to the cutoff we
decided it would be best for him to go
start school as one of the older kids in
class as opposed to the youngest so when
he started talking to Jason we felt we
had made the right decision
Jason is Elliot's imaginary friend I
can't imagine how the other
kindergarteners would have reacted to
the idea of an imaginary friend so it
seemed like starting a bit later would
give him time to go through this phase
and be ready for school next fall the
first time I could remember hearing
about Jason was one evening just as we
were finishing up dinner Elliot had
requested to take some food up to his
room to give to Jason Julianna
inquisitively asked him who Jason was to
which he replied my friend who lives in
the closet upstairs Juliana granted him
permission to take the rest of his food
up as long as he promised to come clean
the dish before he went off to bed I
shot her a look but she being the
free-willed spirit
she has ignored me until Elliot run up
the steps I don't think it was a good
idea to encourage that kind of behavior
but she assured me that having an
imaginary friend was totally normal and
that it would be a good idea to humor
him until he was ready to grow out of it
on his own
hesitantly I agreed and eventually I
would talk to Elliot about Jason on a
day-to-day basis eventually I learned
how to use Jason to my advantage for
example when Elliot didn't want to get
in the car to go to the dentist I would
tell him that Jason said he wanted to go
to the dentist and that Elliot should
come at times Elliot would hardly
mention Jason at all other times it
seemed that Jason was all he wanted to
talk about one time we caught him taking
snacks from the kitchen and he claimed
that they were for Jason Juliana wisely
let this slide and later told me that if
this was the only way that we could get
Elliot to eat it was okay with her and
after many long battles at the dinner
table I was quick to agree I would
oftentimes hear Elliot in his room
talking to Jason and I wondered how long
this phase would last at one point I
asked him what Jason looked like and he
told me that he wore a black snow hat
and had a long fuzzy beard
I was taken off-guard by this since I
had always imagined that Elliot's idea
of Jason was a kid his age I brought
this up with Juliana and she assured me
that it was perfectly normal for a kid
to have an adult as an imaginary friend
after all we are both adults and he
spends most of his time with us so it
makes sense that he would see an adult
at his friend she even said that her
younger sister had an imaginary friend
as a kid who was supposedly an old man
named event which she thinks as a result
of them having spent a lot of time at
their grandparents house back then I had
never had an imaginary friend or any
siblings so I just had to take my wife's
word on all of this that is until one
day that changed everything and still
makes me paranoid we have just gotten
back from the Italian restaurant one of
the only decent places that we can get
Elliot
on a constant basis we parked in the
driveway and decided to go for a short
walk since it was pretty nice out that
evening normally we come into the house
there's a garage but since we had gone
for a walk we entered in the front door
on this occasion as we were taking our
shoes off I heard what I thought the
sound of a cough coming from upstairs
I turned to Julianna wondering if she
had heard it too she looked pale and
shocked as she asked me in a panic
what was that this is probably loud
enough that if someone was upstairs they
might hear Eliot told us that it was
probably just Jason I told my wife and
son to stay put and I went to
investigate when I got upstairs and went
into Elliot's room the light was on in
the window was open I searched the
entire house but was unable to find
anything the windows from Elliot's room
leads onto a section of the roof that is
pretty high up but not impossible jump
down from we later interrogated Elliot
to see if he had left the window open
but he swore he couldn't remember we
tried to get him to tell us that Jason
was real but it was a delicate situation
we didn't want to scare him for life but
we didn't want him to be in danger
either of course at his age I don't
think he fully understood the difference
between real and pretend yet we did end
up calling the police and I have
expected them to find the purpose
someone was living in the closet but
they couldn't find any DNA that didn't
belong to Elliot anywhere in the room
Elliot made friends with a couple kids
on the block and he never really brings
up Jason anymore but it truly chills me
to think that someone could have been in
our house talking to our son in his room
while he slept possibly using him to
sneak food up and to be honest who knows
what else now I check all the upstairs
rooms every night before bed including
the closets and under the bed I tried to
do it when Elliot is not in the room so
he doesn't get to thinking he'll be
starting school in fall and I doubt
we'll really have any confirmation on
whether Jason was just imaginary friend
or not until he's a little bit older
Juliana and I have a second child on the
way now though
so I really hope we find out sooner
rather than later
[Music]
thanks for listening to all daint a
creepypasta your total comes out to
$245,000 but if you like this video
right now I'll waive that fee and give
you everything you just listened to
absolutely free big thank you to end all
for doing this collab with me he's the
one who narrated jason and you can go to
subscribe to his channel for some
incredible cartoon creepypastas be sure
to check out the collaborated together
on his channel as well and remember
subscribe to Susie's world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survived
peace out
[Music]